welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your host eric trexler
today i am joined by a temporary guest
co-host his name is greg knuckles greg
thanks for joining me yeah thanks for
having me on no problem
um before we get into
uh the show today a couple announcements
or i guess reminders
sometimes people ask how they can
support the show
there are many ways to do it if you feel
inclined to do so one way would be
subscribing to the mass research review
and this is an exciting time of year
because our black friday sale is coming
up in about a month give or take
around thanksgiving time so that'll be
coming up around the end of november
another way you could support us is by
subscribing and downloading uh the macro
factor diet app
which you can find in what do they what
is it called there's the google play
store and then the app store yeah for
iphones
um available on both
uh and of course when you're restocking
your supplements uh you could go to
bulksupplements.com
and use our discount code it is sbs pod
at checkout that will save you five
percent on your entire order
and if you like the show uh don't forget
to rate it on itunes or wherever you get
your podcasts uh helps a lot and
since we haven't been remembering to say
that we haven't gotten many reviews
recently so uh yeah if you haven't
reviewed the show yet we would
appreciate it if you did so
and if you're going to leave a bad
review which i wouldn't recommend at
least make it funny right that's the
policy so if you're if you're going to
leave a bad review be completely
unhinged and don't hold back yes um all
right greg road to the stage how's it
going road to the stage is uh
is going pretty well so
within the last week i've had my first
weigh-ins under 239 and 238
that is of course in freedom units
as i mentioned on the lot on the last
podcast the 230s are going to be an
exciting time for me in terms of
milestones and i am a boy who loves
milestones uh 239 means i am halfway
from my very largest to
the goal that i'm trying to get to so
uh after grad school i
the the biggest number i ever saw on the
scale was 278 and i'm trying to get
below 200 so 239 is the midway point um
and i also had my first weigh-in under
238 so that is uh 40 pounds down so a
cool little milestone there
236 will be down 30 pounds since i
started using macro factor
235 will be the lightest i've been in
functionally my adult life uh that's
what i got down to for my wedding and i
have not seen it since
um so yeah yeah exciting stuff coming up
um
and
this this is going to sound like a plug
but this is uh very legitimate
so
uh macro factor has been helping me
navigate
this general point in my weight which
historically has been very rough for me
so
i've had several cuts throughout the
years stall in the kind of 240 to 245
range and what i would notice was that
getting down to about that point
was generally pretty smooth pretty
steady and very manageable
and then i would just hit
just a really hard plateau just hit a
wall
and i would feel like i would need to
drop my calories lower and lower and
lower
and
didn't seem like much happen and then
eventually what i would resort to is
just kind of
just cutting down to
the lowest calorie intake i felt like i
could sustain
um
and turns out i never could sustain it
and eventually i just get
kind of frustrated and say ah [ __ ] it
who who wants to lose weight anyways
that's for the birds
um
but anyway so my experience with macro
factor has validated that experience but
has also helped me
navigate it
thus far successfully in a way that i
have previously
been unable to
so
my energy expenditure in the app
as of like two weeks ago
was like 3 400 calories
and then i did
hit a
very substantial slowdown in weight loss
once i cleared about 244 to 45 on the
scale um
and my calculated energy expenditure in
the app has dropped from like 3 400
calories to
close to 2 900 calories
so
um but no like that's that's out of
weight that historically you've
plateaued at exactly wow so it's
uh
so that that 100 matches my previous
experiences like
and and it's so bizarre to me so
i uh
the i gotta i got above 240 initially
just for a powerlifting meet so i i was
at 220 and i was part of a team going to
a powerlifting meet and we wanted to
sweep as many weight classes as we could
there was another very good 220 at the
gym uh and and i was like around 224 and
he was around 215. so we just decided
he'd be the 220 i'd be the 242 and if i
was going to be 242 i said
well [ __ ] it if i'm going to be a 242
i'm going to be a 242. um
and then
for whatever reason
my body just loved being at like
somewhere in the low 240s it was as if
i encountered a set point that i had
never previously
achieved as a top weight in my life and
ever since that point it's been very
hard to get below that
um
and so like
yeah uh the the the app has been giving
me the data that i have previously
experienced but not
uh
quantified i suppose
um but it's also helped i think keep me
sane and help me
maintain a
more moderate approach to weight loss so
like previously if i would have dropped
my calories by 200 and then 300 and
still not even started getting anywhere
i would have just said ah [ __ ] it we're
going 1500 and just just try to white
knuckle it as long as i can
um
but no it's it's dropped me down to like
2300 calories per day which i mean
for someone my size is pretty low but
it's uh
it's a lot more sustainable than like
1500 would be
so um yeah uh progress has started again
it still feels manageable and
sustainable um
and so yeah i mean
it's uh
it's not the news i would have liked to
have gotten but it still feels good just
from a sense of like
validation right um and i i still feel
pretty good about the road that i'm on
you know it's really interesting because
when you look at the
metabolic adaptation literature
there's two data points right there's
before and after yeah in most studies
and so you don't get insight into that
trajectory
and i did get a question on social media
not long ago asking about you know
should we expect metabolic adaptation to
be linear in nature so if i've already
experienced this much from point x to
point y
can i extrapolate that to point z
you know and i said well probably not
you know i wouldn't anticipate that i
would expect that the more so the more
severe things get
it really starts to ramp up until you
reach like you know we talk about like
ceiling and basement effects like
i don't expect it'll continue in
perpetuity until you're like you know
breaking the laws of physics right so i
was like no probably be pretty flat and
then ramp up a lot and then eventually
it just is maxed out
but i i've never given much thought into
exactly where
it starts to accelerate and how that
might differ from person to person so
that's a really interesting anecdote
along those lines yeah i mean my my
personal experience is that i was born a
240 pound man before i ever reached that
point
that that just seems to be the weight
that my body gravitates towards
um
so yeah i mean we'll we'll see how it
goes from here it very well could be
that
it's just like a weird number that my
body's trying to get to and stay at
and once i like fully break through and
maybe get down to like 235 234 or
something like that it'll say like oh
okay well i guess we're not doing the
240 thing and
uh everything will become easier again
or it could just be a slog the rest of
the way uh the the future is still
shrouded
but um
yeah i mean at the moment that's uh
that's what i'm experiencing
you know it's funny you mentioned that
story of like the power lifting team and
kind of just like filling out the weight
classes people moving around i had a
similar experience as a high school
wrestler like wrestling in america
uh
the the kind of cliche
expectation is everybody's cutting
weight everybody's you know doing water
cuts every week and trying to get as
lean as they can
uh with with my team i was
it was either my sophomore or junior
year but we had seniors
at
140 145 152
right and so the question was do you cut
all the way down to 135 or do you bulk
your way up to 160 because i was kind of
in the middle range at that point
and so i ended up doing just an
unbearable cut down to 135 to the point
that my teachers were i had one i don't
want to exaggerate a teacher pulled me
out of class and said eric
i am horrified by what i've seen happen
to you over the last several weeks
what is happening like they were
concerned about me because the weight
loss was so rapid and precipitous
so i get down to 135 i actually get down
to 132 for good measure
and i freaking failed the hydration
testing that the state does
uh
you have to certify at your body fat or
at your weight class and i failed and so
then they said okay eric why don't you
bulk up to 160.
for the first couple of meets when i was
at 160 everyone on the bus would be like
starving and thirsty and like i haven't
you know i'm this is terrible and i'd be
sitting there like chugging gatorades to
try to get high enough to weigh in and
be able to wrestle at my weight class
and like we were all miserable but for
very different reasons i felt so bad
trying to like
water load for every weigh-in and
everybody else hated me for it but yeah
yeah tricky business but
all right um how how's your uh how's
your road to enlightenment going i would
give it a 4.5 out of 5. all right that's
how it's going and that's not my
assessment um this is a funny thing i
noticed the other day so i started
reading these books about secular
buddhism which is a huge step for me you
know that i i can read but i choose not
to um but
with buddhism there's a lot of lists
yeah and i i think like a lot of
numbered lists i believe
maybe it has something to do with the
fact that it is you know
in the starting days was primarily an
oral tradition and lists are kind of
easier to you know
transmit and remember and things like
that yeah that's kind of speculation on
my part but when you start reading about
buddhism whether you know whether you're
taking a secular or non-secular approach
there are a lot of lists the three of
this the five of this the eight of this
and the noble truth the path yeah the
poisons the eightfold path etc so
there's a lot of numbered lists and
they're important and
you know i think one of the big benefits
of going this route with secular
buddhism is not just
reading it and saying wow that was a
lovely book but actually applying it day
to day and i i felt that this would be
one of those i'm not normally big on
memorization as a learning tool but i
did think if i'm going to apply these
principles throughout the day i need to
know them
like i have to actually have them
committed to memory so i started to make
some flash cards on one of those like
free websites where you can make some
flash cards um i thought it'd be
valuable
uh the other day i was like where did i
make those flash cards so i go to like
look them up and i didn't realize that
they were public
uh but they were uh
and
someone raided my someone raided my
flash cards which i don't understand
what you would who in the
[Music]
why who's going around being like oh
here's a random set of flashcards huh
i'll throw my two cents in was there
was there like a subjective review
attached to the number i wish like uh
overall pretty good but i dinged you
half a point for whatever no it was
somebody was just scrolling through
the depths of the internet found my
buddhism flash cards and said
i'm gonna evaluate this
i i think that alone is just absolutely
hilarious to me but i got a 4.5 out of
five not too bad where'd the other half
a point go
i'm not sure i don't know if if i didn't
have enough breadth to the list if maybe
there were some some typos but
the road to enlightenment uh is going
approximately 4.5 out of 5. sounds good
uh one of the things that has come up
this is kind of trying to
get some fitness into the mix here uh
with the road to enlightenment i've
talked about how i've adopted a
vegetarian diet and there's an
interesting discussion in the uh i think
it was the stronger by science subreddit
it could have been yeah and it was about
whey protein and people who are on
vegetarian or vegan diets were weighing
in on how they feel about consuming whey
protein um and i think it's kind of a
good new a piece of good news if you
like whey protein because it's a really
nice protein source and if you're you
know if you have an interest in maybe
cutting down your utilization of
animal-based food products or if you're
concerned about uh you know
environmental aspects of consuming uh
you know animal products whatever the
case may be no judgment whatsoever but
people were kind of debating well whey
protein it comes from cow milk how do we
feel about that ethically how do we feel
about that environmentally one of the
things that a lot of people don't
recognize about whey protein is
we value it as like gold right people in
the fitness world but people in the food
science world are like man how are we
gonna get rid of all this crap like when
you make i think the number is when you
make a pound of cheese
you end up with nine pounds of whey well
that that's like
what we think of whey like powdered whey
protein the nine pounds is the liquid
form right yeah that's the protein
itself but also the associated liquid
yeah but but
the the general idea is when you make
cheese when you make a number of
conventional dairy products there tends
to be a lot of whey that's left over
yeah and what's really nice is that
there are a lot of
food producers who make these different
dairy products who are truly just trying
to get rid of whey protein and one of
the things that's cool is a lot of the
really big cheese manufacturers
are also
getting into the sport nutrition game
and it's very clear why they have a ton
of whey protein sitting around and there
are environmental issues with just
dumping it and it's it's a really nice
instance where it makes the frogs too
jacked correct yeah
um but it's a really nice instance where
there is this utilization of what would
otherwise be
essentially a wasted by-product and it's
something that makes me feel
extra good about whey protein it's a
great protein source and it's also it
doesn't have quite the environmental
impact and doesn't have quite the
upward nudge on conventional dairy
production that you might expect it has
um i i did try to like contact some
people who are more like
food industry insiders and supplement
insiders to get get nice to try to get a
sense of how much of the whey in
supplements is truly being recycled from
these food operations and how much is
you know
not being you know repurposed waste
product i couldn't get a great answer
for that but seeing like so for example
glanbia is a huge dairy producer and
they've got all sorts of sport nutrition
uh you know protein products within
their brand
pretty good sign that that you're
getting some whey protein that otherwise
would have gone to waste which is which
is pretty cool
and one other thing that you brought to
my attention just the cost
well yeah i mean the the cost would
would certainly incentivize companies to
reuse
whey that would otherwise be discarded
rather than going out of their way to
generate whey which doesn't seem like a
cost-effective way to make a whey
protein supplement well no because i
mean
milk itself is more valuable than whey
protein like you can sell it so a gallon
of milk has about 24-25 grams of whey so
there's basically like one scoop of whey
protein per gallon of milk and a gallon
of milk goes for like yeah at 250 three
bucks depending on where you live
um
and so i mean you know you're not buying
protein supplements that are two and a
half three bucks per serving so
that would be very dumb like yeah you're
getting rid of a three dollar product to
sell like what does whey protein go for
like 25 to 50 cents a serving i don't
know it's something like that so yeah
that would make very little sense
um
or
you know you could convert it to cheese
and there's
uh like
virtually all of the protein and cheese
is casein yeah um and there's there's
like a hundred grams of casein
uh per gallon of milk so you could just
look at cheese labels and look to see
like how much cheese would i need to eat
to get 100 grams of protein in
that that'll give you a rough
idea of how much cheese a gallon of milk
produces and then you can just look at
the price of the cheese uh and it's it's
a lot more than the milk and it's
certainly a lot more than the whey so
just from a pure economics perspective
if someone were
processing milk to get way out of it and
discarding the rest
that would be a
tremendously bad
economic idea yeah uh and
whey protein
whey protein itself would have to be
tremendously more expensive
for that to be the process kind of
underlying it
yeah so once again no judgment at all
when it comes to you know how people
view
the consumption of animal products
um
but i do know at least some people out
there who are like you know i like whey
protein but i'd prefer to utilize less
uh
animal products or conventionally
produce dairy products and things like
that so it's a little bit of good news
for people who find themselves in that
situation another thing that you brought
to my attention that i thought was
really cool
is apparently people are working on some
lab-based approaches to dairy production
so the same way that people are looking
into lab-grown meat
there's a company that's already got
products on the market um they've got
like an ice cream that's getting popular
but apparently what they do is uh they
use fungus
and uh grow this fungus in fermentation
tanks and um based on the genetics that
they kind of mess with for the fungus
apparently it produces whey protein um
just within this kind of fermentation
tank and so they can use that way
protein uh and then go through a whole
bunch of processes and create things
like cheese and ice cream so
um
i'm really intrigued to see where this
goes in the future with uh you know lab
grown meat
lab created dairy products it's it's
pretty uh pretty fascinating and i'll be
excited to see if they can get to a spot
where these things are commercially
available at a price point that makes
sense
sounds good all right so how about feats
of strength what do you got uh so i just
have one this week um
in the most recent episode i had several
because there there had been quite a few
big meets that had occurred um but i i
think at this point uh
major competition season for most
strength sports is done
i think there are some big weightlifting
meets near the end of the year but
the kind of intense competitive calendar
for
powerlifting and strongman i think
mostly wraps up in october
um so it's it's gym lift season
and there was one particularly
impressive gym lift that i came across
and that was daniel clements who is a
ipf 66 kilo or 145 pound power lifter um
he pulled 310 kilos or 683 pounds in
training
that is over the current world record of
303 and a half in that weight class
and uh it was
it was a solid pull it looked smooth it
looked like he probably had a little bit
more in the tank
no straps clean lockout
good control the whole way through like
it it wasn't an iffy lift so uh
you know hopefully he hits that on the
platform soon
i want to be shocked to see him go 700
in the next year year or two um i think
his current best pull in a meet
daniel clements is uh i think it's 297
and a half so like uh
6 55.
so
he's making uh he's making progress at a
at a pretty decent clip
so
the 310 is crazy and if he goes 320 in
the next couple of years that would
obviously be even crazier
good stuff all right
all right so next i've got a
research review segment and i'm going to
try to keep it a bit snappy um get to
the point but this is a topic that we
have
alluded to but we've never really
tackled it head on right so the topic is
going to be
energy restriction and protein
restriction specifically as it pertains
to health and longevity and this this
comes up in the fitness circles all the
time because
if you look at the longevity life
extension
anti-aging circles
the things they talk about seem to be
fully opposed to what you see in the
bodybuilding powerlifting circles right
so the longevity folks they're like how
do i reduce mtor activity uh how low
should i restrict my protein to get all
the good stuff
uh and then of course you know how low
can i get my igf-1 levels while still
staying alive exactly yeah so they you
know in bodybuilding powerlifting we
focus on all these anabolic processes we
focus on overfeeding high protein diets
and things like that and they're very
much looking at the complete opposite of
that energy restriction protein
restriction uh you know there's quite an
interest in fasting things like that and
so it puts a lot of fitness folks in a
precarious spot because they're like
wait a minute
i got into this because i'm interested
in health and this makes me feel like
maybe i'm doing
the opposite of health yeah you know so
it is something that is worth uh at
least briefly addressing and trying to
to put like a practical
uh set of conclusions with it so
when it comes to
energy restriction and protein
restriction
and impacts on health and longevity
i've come across some really excellent
review papers by john speakman and
colleagues and you might remember that
name john speakman because he was
involved in some of the studies we've
talked about lately with um
we talked about metabolic rate over the
lifespan he was involved with that he
was also involved with the one uh
the uh what's the term i'm looking for
um you know when people exercise and
then they compensate by reducing other
types of energy expenditure the uh
constrained energy model uh that that's
so big he's a he's a ponzer collaborator
absolutely yes
so um anyway energy restriction when we
talk about
the mechanisms by which caloric
restriction could impact health and
longevity
um
it's really a long list of mechanisms
because
i mean sensing energy is one of the
basic indicators of where we're at
physiologically so when you have an
abundance of energy
or you have a pretty large deficit with
regards to energy it affects a lot of
different stuff so when people look at
the potential mechanisms lincoln caloric
restriction to increase longevity
they're of course looking at things like
mtor signaling they're looking at
insulin and igf-1 signaling they're
looking at the ampk cascade they're
looking at
sirtuins and autophagy and oxidative
stress and inflammation
every buzzword you've ever heard related
to health is within this enormous list
of potential mechanisms and the reality
is that the energy state of a cell is
very important i mean it is a critical
component of physiology so it's one of
those interventions where you would say
just face value is there any
basic plausibility to believe that this
would meaningfully have an impact and
with energy restriction i think the
answer would be yes you know there's
there's
a long list of plausible mechanisms that
could be at play
so when that's the case you kind of skip
to the next part which is
do we have evidence to believe that
caloric restriction uh actually works
with regards to life extension
and longevity
and there is some evidence that caloric
restriction works
largely coming from
insect studies and rodent studies so
when you look at rodent models mice and
rats
you'll see that caloric restriction
uh with a magnitude of like 30
restrictions so instead of eating normal
food cutting that down to 70
of what
you know the rodent would normally eat
uh that can extend lifespan up to like
20
in in some of the studies you see that's
a fairly typical
uh fairly typical number
and
what's interesting is that the
uh
there are some instances in which the
the effect is pretty dramatic so if you
look at pretty
extreme caloric restriction protocols
you might see uh increases in longevity
that are up at like 50
extension of lifespan and there is a a
pretty clear relationship in rodent
research between the degree of caloric
restriction and the extent to which
lifespan is increased so if you're
looking at you know 20 30 percent uh
caloric restriction a study might only
find you know 20
for example uh extension of lifespan but
if you're getting up into like you know
60 70
energy restriction which is
awful
like you think of what if i only ate 30
or 40 percent of what i typically eat
while very carefully trying to avoid
malnutrition that that's what we're
talking about there and in in some
rodent studies that has increased uh
lifespan by up to 50 which is notable so
just to put some numbers on that so if
if we were to assume and we'll get into
the details in a second here but if we
were to assume that like a 50 increase
in lifespan
you know it basically speakman and
colleagues did some modeling and said
okay what might that look like uh you
know in human beings i mean we're
talking about
uh a male
increasing their life expectancy from 78
to 117 right or female increasing their
life expectancy from 83 years old to
124.5 years old
so if we could find
uh
a tolerable intervention that did that i
mean that's a meaningful extension of
lifespan yeah
but
the magnitude of effect i mean of course
we'll
for the moment just kind of here man if
i had to reduce calorie intake by 70
percent
to live
more than a hundred years
dude just put me in the ground at 70.
like those
those additional 40 years are not worth
it i i agree with you i agree with you
for sure um but but the reality of these
interventions is
the magnitude of the effect is going to
depend on the magnitude of caloric
restriction but also the time at which
restriction begins so you might look at
that and say well hey maybe when i turn
76 i'll you know i'll get really into
this and it'll matter to me and then
i'll just kind of drop my calories and
live to you know 120. that's not
necessarily how it works it's about the
degree of restriction and the time
course of restriction so they they did
some modeling in one of their review
papers where they
uh you know they looked at okay how many
extra years beyond
the expected value of like 78 let's say
78 years old
how much more do you get with a given
uh percentage of caloric restriction
that was done at a certain point in your
life right so for example a 30 energy
restriction done pretty early in life so
uh if you are only 20
of the way to that 78-year uh life
expectancy uh so pretty early in life if
you do a pretty severe restriction you
might get like an extra 11 years or so
right
uh but if you're doing this restriction
you're applying it at at the age of 70.
there are i'm sorry 70
into your life which we're assuming is
78 years uh
we're talking about less than a third of
a year of extension if we're talking
about 15 to 30 percent energy
restrictions so
the timing matters the magnitude matters
but
one of the questions that comes up here
among many which we'll get into one of
the questions that comes up for me is
what would happen
so this table shows from 20 to 80 of
lifespan on set
what about 10
i feel like the uh
i feel like the logical implication of
this is like if you want your kids to
live a long time start starving them
from a young age that's absolutely not
that was maybe a little bit too spicy
and salacious to include in this table i
find it
uh very intriguing that they just
happened to start it at 20 of lifespan
um
i don't know do without what you will i
i'm thinking maybe they figured that
malnutrition is bad
and uh during int you know periods of
intensive growth well but
fair enough you might want to
eat and stuff 20 is still smack dab in
the middle of puberty for most people
yeah like just using round numbers if we
assume someone's living 75 years 20 is
15 years old the moral of the story is
feed your kids
that is not the moral of the story that
is my moral of this if you strictly
interpret this table
we're not doing that uh
okay uh so eric is not saying starve
your kids speakman is saying starve your
kids so if you have
if you have any complaints no
i'm completely joking um
okay so
one of the questions that comes up uh
people talk about calorie restriction
but they also talk about protein
restriction and this is what captures
the attention of a lot of fitness folks
is wait a minute i thought protein was
good now you're telling me low protein
makes me live longer so
here's where it gets interesting if you
look at the insect data
that data seems to indicate
that protein restriction is very
impactful and potentially even more
important than calorie restriction when
it comes to extending lifespan
however when you look at rodent data
it tells a different story the rodent
data would indicate that energy
restriction is far more impactful than
protein restriction so if you look at
the effects of rodent studies where they
do calorie restriction with protein
restriction
lifespan doesn't seem to differ when you
compare that to studies where they do
calorie restriction without protein
restriction so the calorie restriction
wherever protein happens to be seems to
really be pulling a lot of the weight
when it comes to life extension in
rodents
and when i think of myself you know
my self-image i don't think of myself as
an insect
you know i'm i'm am i a mouse
pretty much you know i i'm much more of
a mouse than i am an insect in my
opinion yeah so based on that alone and
i consider myself pretty
pretty reminisce
pretty reminiscent of the capybara yeah
that that's that's the big rodent right
uh dude those things are so cute they
they are cute i'm checking this to make
sure that this is real time fact check
yeah this is the first thing we've said
on the podcast thus far that i feel the
need to fact check i mean that that is a
cute animal i just i'm not certain that
it's necessarily a rodent but i think it
is it is a rodent yeah uh
yeah if you've never looked at pictures
of capybaras especially baby cappy
bearers i i know you have yeah dear
listener if you've never checked out
pictures of baby capybaras they're so
cute um
definitely the best rodent
on this planet
yeah i really appreciate that
contribution you got it uh now i don't
have that much prepared for this episode
so i'm i'm just trying to slide in with
with capybara takes when i
have the opportunity i apologize yeah
that's great
now
when we look at the rodent data it would
not be fair to say that protein
restriction has
no impact
it is simply
much smaller than the impact of caloric
restriction and the relationship
is
curvilinear and the exact uh ranges are
pretty important to look at so when you
look at protein restriction
in in rodents you have to get to pretty
low intakes to see noteworthy benefits
in terms of lifespan extension so i mean
we're talking about protein making up a
single digit percentage of your total
energy intake and your total energy
intake is low uh if you're combining
this with caloric restriction so
it's a pretty extreme intervention you
would have to pursue
to see this type of effect in rodents
and then you know looking at the other
end of the spectrum you know where does
lifespan start to fall
when protein intake gets high
um
it re you really don't start to see that
until up around the like
60
of your diet coming from protein like
maybe you could argue it happens a
little before that but
i mean it's up around 50 or 60 of your
calories coming from protein
and when i say you i mean mice again
where we start to see
a kind of a downward uh trajectory for
uh lifespan so
there is an effect technically but
within the ranges that are typically
considered
feasible and tolerable in terms of you
know protein percent of energy
uh it just doesn't seem to matter much
within the thick of that distribution so
the food restriction effect as it
relates to lifespan and rodents is is
largely driven by calories uh and not
much coming from from protein
restriction itself
um
and just to put some numbers on that for
context um
if you were to reduce your protein
levels by eighty percent uh for a rodent
again that that would increase their
median lifespan by like 15 percent
but if you were to reduce calorie intake
by half so instead of reducing by 80
percent if you're reducing calorie
intake by 40
the median increase in lifespan would be
twice as big so so it's it's a a much
smaller degree of restriction and a much
bigger impact on life span and rodents
but
you know the next point is the fact that
simply put humans are not insects and
they're not rodents so we have to keep
that in mind
i was getting concerned there for a
second greg one of the things we've
talked about uh off the air is the fact
that
humans are enormous outliers when it
comes to longevity yes and there are a
number of figures on the internet that
are fascinating to look at where they'll
put many different species
completely different types of organisms
and they they tend to fall on these
tight lines that are scaled to like
uh heart rate for example right um or
either heart rate or metabolic rate yeah
heart rate metabolic rate but there's
all these different ways of scaling
uh longevity to blank and what's really
fascinating is that you'll see all these
different organisms from completely
different types of you know animals and
and stuff
and they all fall on this line and then
humans are just way out in left field
with this unusually long lifespan yeah
we wouldn't be that huge of outliers if
we were birds yeah because birds live
longer than most other animals relative
to body size heart rate metabolic rate
however you want to quantify it
we we would be
particularly long-lived birds for our
size but not
just crazy outliers but for mammals it's
it's outrageous yeah um
humans live far longer than we would be
predicted to based on our our basic
physiology yeah so that's important to
keep in mind is that we are
we are outliers and so when we are
trying to extrapolate from
animal models that are not outliers
there are generalizability issues that
are kind of built into that
another thing to keep in mind is when we
look at this rodent data which i think
most would agree is probably more
applicable than insect data
um
unless you're really into ecti steroids
and then you're you're all about yeah if
you if you have not taken our
terkesterone
advice maybe you should pay more
attention to the insect research um but
anyway uh
rodents a lot of times when they're in a
lab environment and they're able to live
out their days
uh cancer is a really leading cause of
death
but when you look at humans we have a
much higher prevalence relatively
speaking of
issues related to metabolic syndrome and
cardiovascular disease
we have different stuff to worry about
that that caps our longevity to some
extent so there are certainly some uh
some issues
with generalizability that we have to
keep in mind when we look at this
literature
um
aside from that a few other caveats to
keep in mind when you think about this
topic first of all
something that you kind of alluded to at
the very beginning
before we start talking about practical
application of caloric restriction you
have to keep in mind
those are enormous degrees of caloric
restriction even for the more modest
approaches like 30 percent caloric
restriction is not fun
uh 70
isn't
let's not even joke about the idea that
that's feasible because it's just not
right so um
when you look at the rodent data as far
as we can tell
rodents in caloric restriction studies
are very hungry and they don't get less
hungry
and that's really important when it
comes to practical application i i think
we might even if you were really
enthusiastic about this and you're like
oh i can do that amount of restriction
and it's not a big deal and i can stick
with it like i'm sure i'll get used to
it
there's nothing in the animal research
that would indicate that that there's a
a point at which you're like oh yeah
this is fine i love eating only half of
what i used to yeah the hunger is
persistent because again
we're not we're not talking about if if
you were chronically overeating uh to a
really high degree and then cutting down
to like a fairly typical level we're
talking about restricting from a
baseline typical level of intake you
know so doing 70 percent restriction
from like a 2000 2500 calorie diet yeah
something like that i mean it's a basic
physiological drive like it makes sense
like people with uh people with pretty
intense sleep disorders don't stop being
sleepy right you know like there's
there's
the human body is very adaptable but
there are limits to
what it can adapt to and to how much it
can adapt yeah exactly and so uh there
were a couple major um you know in one
of these review papers that i'll link in
the show notes uh speakman and
colleagues talk about a couple things
that the animal studies simply can't
tell us about caloric restriction first
of all
we don't know if they're feasible for
humans we don't know if the degree of
restriction required is something that
can actually feasibly be implemented for
long enough to see benefit
and then another question is
whether or not we will necessarily have
the same
benefits you know like i mentioned there
are different causes of death
that have to be considered uh you know
we do not have the same exact
longevity limiters that
might take the life of a mouse in a lab
and one of the really creative things
they brought up that's really insightful
is the fact that
speakman has what he calls the clean
cupboards hypothesis
and uh you know one of the things that
the animals
you'll see in these
rodent studies is
they don't really have to do much in
terms of activities of daily living you
know food is provided they're just kind
of chilling there and they don't have
the same degree of exposure to like
pathogens they don't have the same
issues to overcome when it comes to like
if they needed to heal a wound right
so speakman's
clean cupboards hypothesis talks about
how
you know when we restrict calories
animals humans whatever
we do a lot of catabolic things that are
simply just to try to make energy
balance work we're just trying to
survive an energy crisis
and some of those catabolic things may
be good for longevity um you know so we
might reduce fat storage in our liver we
might uh reduce our visceral fat we
might increase the degree of
the balance between autophagy and
apoptosis where we are you know kind of
tuning up some of our damaged cells and
recycling some of those uh you know
broken down proteins and organelles and
things like that
so there are some aspects of this
catabolic approach that might be helpful
for longevity
but it's not all good and so
in the clean cupboards hypothesis he
kind of creates this this work of
this kind of fictitious scenario where
somebody's stuck in a house
and they have to make do and they're
really hungry right so of course at some
point they're going to clean out the
cupboards and eat all the stuff and
that's good
but you know they might get to the point
where they're so damn hungry that they
eat the house plants right that's not
good that's not what's supposed to
happen that's not beneficial
to anybody it makes the house uglier
it's not really helping them out eating
house plants and stuff less oxygen
yes so the idea is there are some things
that get kind of catabolized along the
way there are some catabolic processes
and there are some mechanisms of energy
conservation that do not directly
promote longevity and could have
downsides and to put that into more
practical terms like
you could have impaired immune function
because you're so energy restricted and
you don't have the energy to fuel a
proper immune response to a pathogen or
you might have a wound and it just won't
heal
and that's not good so when we're in
this energy restricted state there are a
mixture of pros and cons when it comes
to longevity
one of the um
one of the hypotheses that i've seen
for
how the the the ways that energy
restriction can improve longevity
is that um
like via reduced uh immune function like
basically
when there's some sort of of insult that
would generally provoke um an
inflammatory response
if you have reduced immune function you
have less inflammation so you have fewer
cells that were previously undamaged
that end up being damaged in the
uh
in the inflammatory cascade and so then
you get less cell turnover and the more
cell turnover you have the quicker you
start eating into telomeres and so if
you can
constrain that process to some degree
uh maybe it can just slow down the aging
process a little bit and like you're
getting that that's all well and good
until you have something that needs to
be addressed quickly right like if you
get sick with something and you have
just less glucose and atp for your
immune system well now something that
could have been a small problem might
become a big problem yeah or if you have
a significant wound to recover from so
yeah i mean it it's something that
um
perhaps if spread over an entire life
span might have some benefits but in a
lot of discrete instances on kind of
like a day-to-day or week to week basis
it could have some very notable
downsides as well
right and i think you know one of the
other things to keep in mind is that if
you play out this process
to a really extreme example where you're
really restricting energy and you're
you're also by default or maybe on top
of that purposefully restricting protein
now we start to to deal with some of the
things that really limit the health span
of a human adult and so when we get
older sarcopenia is critically
important it's something that can be
very limiting and that's the age-related
loss of muscle mass and muscle function
and so you know when sarcopenia really
sets in and we lose strength and we lose
muscle mass
that can threaten our independence our
ability to carry out activities of daily
living and so uh you know you also have
to worry when we take these rodent
models for example and look at severe
energy and protein restriction well how
do we balance that against the you know
you know with within an older adult if
we do severe energy and protein
restriction in the absence of resistance
training we might run into some serious
issues where sarcopenia is a limiting
factor and you know and then you start
talking about fall risk and then you
start looking at the the literature the
data on
the survivability of a fall with a
serious fracture in old age is really
eye-opening you know and so it's it's
not quite as simple as taking molecular
mechanisms and saying yep that works for
me let's let's do that right uh so when
we talk about extra extrapolating that
to humans
who have to still carry out these
activities of daily living and have
enough enough protein and enough energy
to support the maintenance of important
lean tissues
it gets really complicated here so
when it comes to practical guidance i
think there are things that we can
glean from some of this caloric
restriction literature um
applying it strictly and literally is i
think just completely not feasible
um
but you know when we look at what limits
humans in terms of health span and
lifespan
you can see uh some benefits of not
being in
a
chronic state of excessive
surplus of energy right so we can take
these mechanisms and turn them the other
way and say like okay well you probably
don't want to spend
really really enormous periods of your
life chronically over feeding to a
really uh extreme degree i think that
that's a fairly clear takeaway
exercise i think with humans
has the potential to have an additive or
even synergistic effect when you combine
it with some degree of caloric
restriction so
i think there's some decent evidence
i'll link to a review paper that simply
being in a state of high energy flux
is good metabolically so if you take
someone who's not restricting their
calories to the point of being in a
deficit but maybe they were overeating
and were kind of in a process of weight
gain you say let's just get down to
energy balance and increase exercise you
know
so we're not losing any weight
whatsoever but we're increasing energy
flux and we're no longer in a surplus
that alone can do some pretty important
things when it comes to a variety of
risk factors for chronic disease like we
can see some big impacts on how that
affects people's liver how it affects
their glycemic control how it affects
their their brain and their vascular
tissues there's a lot of really cool
stuff that can be done in the absence of
weight loss there well i mean to to kind
of address this with with a blunt
instrument instead of looking at
individual mechanisms i i feel like that
plays pretty well
with the uh meta-analysis on step count
and all calls mortality rates yeah that
i posted on instagram a couple weeks
back
[Music]
you see a
not quite linear but roughly linear um
decrease in all cause mortality risk as
step counts go from
i think on the lower end like 2 700
steps per day
up to the highest range where they had
data i think was like 17 000 steps per
day but just
just precipitous drop off in all calls
mortality rates as step counts go up
which
you know in in free living humans who
aren't like
super competitive athletes like step
counts are a
pretty decent proxy for
general physical activity and energy
flux yeah
so
i think
when you talk about
taking this information and saying okay
well what what can a human
really glean from this literature and
apply
i think the general principle is i don't
think there's anything wrong with having
periods of life
when you are over feeding for the
purpose of building muscle building
strength for athletic purposes
but i think in general when you look
back over a 78-year lifespan you'd like
to look back and say okay for much of
that time i was not acutely in an
enormous energy surplus and i had a
reasonably high degree of energy flux i
think that's the best we can do to try
to
leverage some of these mechanisms but
the idea in my opinion of having a
straightforward application of this
energy restriction research
i just don't think it's feasible the
protein restriction seems less relevant
to humans and i think when you do the
protein restriction you make big
sacrifices when it comes to health span
specifically related to sarcopenia later
in life so
while there are interesting mechanisms
here i think the key thing is
when i focus on what i can do for
longevity it's you know making sure i
have a nutritious diet making sure that
my energy flux is high a high level of
physical activity
keeping energy balance generally in
check and if you wanted to you know
really start tipping the scales you
might say instead of just being an
energy balance with high energy flux
maybe i will try to establish a deficit
and get down to a body fat range i feel
really good about and then you'll you'll
probably be experiencing some additional
benefit of that slight degree of energy
restriction and then achieving a body
fat level that seems to correlate with
some positive things related to
cardiometabolic risk factors so
for now i kind of think that's the best
we can do uh and and so the the thing
that fitness people
will uh
or should i think be encouraged by is
the fact that
it doesn't look like
uh protein restriction within a normal
range of protein intakes is necessary or
will necessarily be helpful uh you know
if you wanted to try to leverage some of
this protein restriction literature we'd
be talking about
very very low protein intakes that would
have
other problems associated with it when
it comes to longevity
physical activity good maintaining a
body weight where you're healthy is good
so there's stuff to take from it but
yeah i don't think we can use the rodent
stuff and say perfect i'm going to do
that yeah i mean i think one of the
drawbacks of the rodent literature
independent of the fact that we're not
rodents
is one of the things you mentioned is
you know for the most part these are
just mice that are kind of chilling in
their cage and
being fed a
particular amount
and you just kind of see what happens i
mean with free living humans you're also
dealing with behavioral adaptations and
so
you know there are obviously tremendous
benefits of
uh exercise either just from
yeah just moving around doing day-to-day
stuff or like dedicated
training like more intense exercise like
both of those are very good things
and so like we're not we're not mice
like we have behavioral adaptations to
energy balance and how we feel
and
i would be shocked if most people doing
50
caloric restriction are moving around
very much right and so you know if
you're potentially getting some benefits
from
uh energy restriction but that is
necessarily coming along with pretty
large reductions in activity levels
you might be losing more than you're
gaining yeah and one thing that's
interesting is that you know while the
caloric restriction evidence is pretty
good for mice and for rats
um
comparatively speaking the effects of
exercise aren't that great
for their longevity
um it's not negligible but it's it's
it's not that great yeah and i think
that's one of those things that really
highlights those key differences is that
for humans who are main
in many cases are our main issues
related to health span and lifespan are
can i maintain activities of daily
living exercise is critical can i
maintain my cardio metabolic health
exercise is critical
and looking at these rodent studies it's
just a completely different context when
it comes to what's important for
longevity so
i just to reiterate and kind of put a
conclusion on it i think
the information about physical activity
and energy flux and simply not being in
a surplus i i think we can leverage that
without necessarily saying hey i need to
get shredded to be healthy
if you
carry that out over time and you have
the ability to sustainably induce
an energy deficit rather than just being
at maintenance with high energy flux i
think even better you know but but it's
it's critically important to recognize
that we can have some of these really
tremendous benefits without necessarily
saying the goal is weight loss
the goal can be
weight maintenance with high physical
activity and i think there can be huge
longevity benefits from that
sounds good to me
all right that went way longer than i
thought but i hope at least three or
four people enjoyed it so i mean i
enjoyed it i thought it was fun i got to
talk about capybaras yeah
okay so greg obviously macro factor is
in full swing we've got
a thriving community of users who are
loving it a lot of great interactions in
the facebook group and the subreddit and
on the podcast we came out with a new
segment called tech support where we
talk a little bit about new stuff in the
app or we talk about different features
within the app so what is going on with
tech support this week yeah so i've got
uh two things to talk about
so the first tech support related thing
to mention
uh is if you download macro factor
and you start playing around with it try
swiping things so one of the things that
we wanted to do with our food logger is
have
quick
so we wanted it to have all of the
functionality that someone might want to
have in a food logger
but we also wanted it to be as easy and
quick as possible to do
all of the things one would want to do
one of the things that has affected me
previously with food logging is just how
long it can take to log things sometimes
like i am not particularly interested in
uh you know trying to spend two three
minutes to log every meal that i eat um
so we wanted to make things quick which
meant we didn't want
actions to be nested behind like two or
three
different things you had to click on to
get to a particular action
and so
the
the action pattern that we've settled on
that allows you to do everything you'd
want to do and do it quick
is swiping things and that has been
confusing to some people because that
isn't a common thing that you're
expected to do in most food loggers um
most most of the time it is just
clicking stuff so sometimes just a click
sometimes a long a long press
very rarely are you going to be swiping
things and so there's a lot of
functionality in our food logger that i
think people are
not discovering and getting frustrated
because they don't discover it because
they don't think to swipe things so
um just for some backstory i met my
girlfriend on a dating app and that was
the one thing that i insisted upon i
said it has to be a swipe-based app so
that that's my fault yeah it had great
success for you previously so you said
anything with the swipes are good
correct uh so for example there have
been a lot of questions like how do i
delete a food from
uh from my timeline you just give it a
long swipe to the left uh how do you
copy and paste something you give it a
short swipe to the left click copy paste
it wherever you want um
two very exciting new features that
should have
uh gone out already by the time this
episode airs if not it will be very soon
after this episode airs they're already
on
on my device on the internal beta
and they've been submitted to the app
store and play store so they should be
out within the next day or two depending
on how long approval takes
is uh explode recipes so for example if
you have a saved recipe and you want to
log it as its constituent ingredients
either just because it makes your food
log look prettier
or because you know like let's say you
eat the same four foods for breakfast
every day but the
uh amounts of each ingredient might
differ a little bit you might want to be
able to save that as a recipe but then
have a way to log each food individually
so you can easily change the amounts
that's nested behind a swipe function
and then multi-add is here as well so
if you do a single search or if you go
to search and your smart history pops up
and you want to be able to add three
four five things to your plate all at
once without having to go back to the
search bar every time that's also a
swipe feature so within the search
results that come up you swipe click log
swipe click log
so anyway there's a lot of cool stuff
behind
swipe features
and once you get a feel for it it does
make food logging a lot quicker
but
i think that the
on our end i think the discoverability
of that could use some work um because i
think people just aren't thinking to try
to swipe things uh and that's that's on
us we're trying to get people used to a
new
um a new thing to do with your fingers
in a food logger uh that people just
aren't thinking to do but as part of
getting the word out and making people
aware of it uh tech support segment a
lot of people using macro factor listen
to the podcast so
you know if if you're thinking like hey
what can i do with this thing in my food
log or on my timeline or on my plate or
whatever try swiping it uh there's a lot
of cool stuff behind the swipes try
everything try tapping try swiping try
long pressing yeah uh yeah there there's
a lot of
there is
crazy functionality um
nested behind as few actions as possible
but uh yeah to to make that work um you
know we do use long presses more heavily
than other diet apps we do use swipes
i don't know if anyone else uses the
swipes at all um but yeah so that's
that's just something to note and keep
in mind
and then a slight update on a previous
tech support segment um
and this this brings me great joy to let
you know uh so
i think either the first or second tech
support segment
we talked about database issues and how
really
the only consistent complaint we got
from
users outside of the us and canada
was that you pull up the barcode scanner
you try to scan something nothing comes
up
and just
quite limited food databases outside of
the us and canada
that is going to be changing for
a lot of you guys very soon so
if you live in the uk
australia
ireland or new zealand we're adding a
new food database which should be here
very soon
and by very soon what i mean is uh i
sent the wire transfer to the company
yesterday yeah we paid for it yeah so we
better get it soon so
we've uh
we've already made the payment there
will be a little bit so you know don't
necessarily expect it tomorrow there
will be some engineering involved and
some testing involved
to make sure that the app doesn't get
confused when you pull up the barcode
scanner because it'll be trying to look
at nutritionx results and results from
this other database
so yeah it may not necessarily be
instantaneous but we have made that
purchase that will be coming very soon
um
and we've already started
kind of mulling around
uh and investigating some more concrete
ideas to improve database coverage
outside of u.s can't canada
uk australia new zealand ireland
um
it's going to be a bit more challenging
to
[Music]
fully cover everyone excellently
the
the countries that we're already
handling that's kind of the low hanging
fruit
but
i i'm excited with the progress we've
made so far because on the last tech
support segment when i talked about this
i was thinking it would probably be the
type of thing where like if we could if
we could get there in two to three
months we'd be pretty excited about it
um but now we're talking
best case scenario time scale of days
worst case scenario probably time scale
of weeks uh but that that is going to be
coming very very soon
yeah it's really exciting stuff yes and
i also
have a quick uh stronger by science
article discussion segment uh so we
recently had a guest article from
cameron gill
uh about reverse nordic curls otherwise
known as i think i saw someone call them
uh quad fallouts or something uh i
previously to this article i'd always
just refer to them as uh
bodyweight knee extensions
so
i think it's a very good article i
enjoyed it a lot um
they have become so reverse nordic curls
or body weight knee extensions have
become a staple of my training now that
i've started training in my basement
instead of in a gym
so one of the drawbacks with a lot of
like barbell exercises or just bilateral
exercises in general
is
that they
primarily target the monoarticular heads
of the quads so your vastus medialis
vastus lateralis fastest intermedius
but most exercises that involve
simultaneous knee and hip extensions so
you know you're talking quads you're
talking split squats you're talking step
ups all of that stuff they tend to have
really low rectus femoris activation
which makes sense logically it's kind of
the same thing i've been talking about
for years with the hamstrings in the
squat but in reverse so if you're trying
to extend your knee but also extend your
hip it doesn't make a ton of sense
biomechanically to rely heavily on your
rectus femoris because if it's
contracting hard sure that's good for
knee extension but it's going to be
opposing hip extension to some degree so
uh your nervous system tries to rely on
the monoarticular heads of the quads as
much as possible um
and so it can be challenging to train
the rectus femoris well
at least in a knee extension context uh
outside of you know just being able to
use a knee extension machine
but with uh with body weight uh or with
reverse nordic curls just with body
weight um
you can you can hammer the [ __ ] out of
your rectus femoris like the first time
i did them uh that was that was the
first thing i noticed like i was
starting to get a pump in my quads and i
was like
this pump is different than the pump i'm
used to and then i realized like oh yeah
it's the head of the quads that i
literally never use
and so yeah it's been good uh you can
get just a great quadricep stimulus
without spinal loading which um you know
can definitely be challenging uh outside
of you know if you don't have access to
a leg press or a hack squat machine even
though i guess hack squat loads the
spine as well but it's not much
um
but yeah it's a really good just general
accessory lift for the quads it's a good
way to uh target your rectus femoris uh
especially in the context of body weight
training anecdotally for me so i've
talked about several times i've been
playing more basketball um
my knees don't love basketball as it is
they never have they especially don't
like it now that i'm losing weight
because the thing is now that i'm losing
weight i'm more vertical uh
at uh in the 270s
your boy's not getting off the ground
very far but like once i got below about
250 i was like i don't know man i can
start challenging at the rim a little
more i can start going for more rebounds
uh
and so
it's good i'm better at basketball now
that i've lost some weight but my knees
were really starting to take a beating
and uh started doing more reverse nordic
curls
i would say in like june or july
and the first time i did them my knees
despised them like i i tried to do them
strict hips extended going all the way
back i got about midway down and my
knees said [ __ ] you greg we're not doing
this um so i humbled myself i i did some
exercise regression for the first time
in a long time i i'm not i'm not a
regression guy
um
i i generally just say give me the
hardest version of an exercise but i'll
just not do it for many reps i
i humbled myself i regressed
so instead of doing reverse nordic curls
with full hip extension which makes it
quite challenging
if if you can't do that yet you can just
flex your hips that
brings your body center of mass closer
to your knees
and so it makes it a lot easier so i
started by doing regressed uh reverse
nordic curls uh my knees could tolerate
that so i i basically put the
the amount of stress on them
that caused uh some degree of discomfort
not pain so i kind of rode that line
and as my knees started feeling better
and as i started getting stronger at
them i
just progressed to being able to do
strict uh reverse nordic curls over time
and this is purely an n equals one thing
purely anecdotal they've made my knees
feel so much better and i can take so
much more basketball now and so much
more jumping without my knees getting
mad at me so
for me personally they've been just good
for a general quad stimulus uh they seem
to be pretty good for
again i'm not saying this will
generalize to everyone but for me
personally they seem to have been quite
good for my knee health um and it's a
good article you should check it out and
if you've been thinking to yourself like
hey i have minimal equipment and i want
to
do something for my quads that is not
just more squats uh give them a try it's
it's a very easy exercise to set up and
it's a very good exercise
yeah it was a great article by cameron
um it's got a video the article
goes into depth about how to execute the
lift how to progress it really really
comprehensive work so be sure to check
it out this is one of those exercises
uh i've talked about this before but
there was like this one particular week
uh early early early covid where it was
like
every gym on the planet was like okay
we're all shutting and so if you were
like me and you had a whole
roster of clients you're like oh i need
to make a lot of home-based programs
immediately with
minimal equipment or no equipment right
and looking back i wish i had more
familiarity with this exercise and all
the different variations and you know
steps of progression it would have been
such a valuable tool to utilize back
then so uh
the best time to learn about it is as
soon as possible i think especially with
how many people are still currently
training out of home gyms it's a really
really versatile really valuable
exercise
all right so uh to wrap up the show here
i am going to answer a couple of
questions that i've gotten in various
places
um
and i'm still uncertain about exactly
which ones i want to answer but i
definitely want to answer at least a
couple protein ones to stay on theme
talked a little bit about protein
restriction
this one is probably the most on theme
this was submitted by half guard hipster
i forget where because i just kind of
accumulate these questions and i i never
get to them and at this point i have no
idea where this came from well seen as
the username that you copied and pasted
includes how many points it has and how
long ago it was posted i'm going to
assume this was reddit that would make
sense uh but i don't have enough
familiarity with reddit
to have the whole
format down
so the question was uh you know
we've pretty extensively talked about
the range of protein intake for
maximizing muscle growth
and this individual was asking about the
other side of that spectrum so what's
the lowest protein intake that someone
could eat and still build you know an
appreciable amount of muscle assuming
that they have adequate calories in
their diet and they're training
effectively and things like that so
instead of looking at the top end of
kind of optimization with the range like
what's the
if i wanted to have a low protein diet
what should i try to get up to in order
to make sure i'm doing pretty okay
and honestly i think one of the easiest
ways to answer this is just by like a
quick visual assessment from some
meta-analyses on the topic so
these are two metas about protein intake
and
hypertrophy or increases in lean mass
that we've already talked about on the
podcast so there's tagawa and colleagues
which is fairly recent within the last
year or two i think there's the morton
paper from 2018 which is uh it's a
classic a
very popular meta on protein
so if we start out with the morton paper
and we just kind of visually assess
um you know the classic figure that
everybody talks about with that paper
where they get the the kind of typical
optimized range of 1.6 to 2.2 grams of
protein per kilogram of body mass when
we look there um you know what's really
interesting is that
people are doing pretty okay
kind of across the board um
and i think that's something that's
underappreciated is the fact that
training
matters very bigly like training is
without question training is what is
stimulating the accretion of muscle
tissue and lean body mass
having the availability of protein you
know having sufficient protein around is
permissive it facilitates the process
that is largely stimulated by the actual
training you know i mean the training is
really pushing things forward and the
protein intake is facilitating that so
if you look at the people uh you know
the the data points within within this
figure there are people down around you
know
1.2 grams per kilogram per day who are
doing
just fine uh and i i would actually say
that that's probably about where i'd say
if if you're lifting and you're like i'm
not all about the high protein stuff but
i'll meet you halfway how much do i
really have to get in uh you know
looking at this figure as low as 1.2
grams per kilogram seems pretty fine to
be honest yeah i mean the the thing that
people
i think miss about this figure is like
ultimately they were doing a break point
analysis so they assumed
there's going to be a positive slope up
to a particular point and then it's
going to be flat
and so
where where is that break point like
where does it go from being a positive
relationship to flat
and the figure includes a confidence
interval for that break point it's
represented by a bidirectional arrow uh
near the x-axis
and i think people i think people just
miss that confidence interval so
the studies included in the paper
had protein intakes of about 0.9 to 2.3
grams per kilogram per day so 0.9 to 2.3
is the range we're working with the
confidence interval for the break point
was from 1 to 2.2
so
i mean the
the
the potential range for
where gains go from being positive with
increased protein intake to flat uh
spanned almost the entire range of
protein intakes of the studies included
in the meta-analysis so
uh to to treat 1.6 as if that is the
number and there's no possible other
number that it could be based on the
research um
that that's just simply untrue that's
the the paper people site to make a
claim such as that does not support that
claim right yeah and then you know if we
look at the tagawa paper
um
they had a number of figures they did
one of those things where there was like
a figure with nine panels and it was a
thorough way to do it it's like what if
we controlled for this but what if we
controlled for that and what if you're
lifting what if you're not lifting but
you are exercising you know there's all
these different scenarios but i think
the most representative panel of that
particular figure was panel b
it was the relatively unadjusted values
in people who are lifting and it was
looking at total protein intake you know
grams per kilogram per day and then on
the y-axis you know looking at those
increases in i think this was fat free
mass if memory serves but what you see
is that you know from
this doesn't have the individual data
points it just kind of has the trend
line and the 95 confidence band around
that trend line
and it's a non-linear um
approach to modeling so it's not just a
straight line there there's a bend to
the line and what you see is that
there's a pretty steep upward trajectory
going from like
0.7 grams per kilogram up to
i don't know what is that 1.3 ish would
you say yeah like 1.3 1.4 yeah 1.3 1.4
and then it starts to flatten out quite
a bit it's still going up it's not flat
but it's flatter
and so i don't know when i triangulate
you know these these kind of meta looks
at the literature
compare that with some anecdotal
experience compare that with some
interventions look at the magnitude of
effect i mean sometimes you'll see you
know like oh high protein was better in
this study and it was like yeah but it
was like you jump from 1.4 to like 2.6
grams per kilogram and you got like an
extra you know 0.8 kilograms of fat free
mass you know so
at that point how much you know how big
is that effect how much does it really
matter when you're completely
overhauling your nutritional approach in
order to achieve it
i don't know i'd say my numbers like
if you wanted to shoot for the lowest
end that you you really feel like you
can feel okay about i'd say probably
around 1.2 grams per kilogram do you
feel similarly or do you have a
different number you'd throw out no i i
agree yeah and honestly once again
i'm a nutrition guy so i have every
reason in the world to tell you you need
to dot every i cross every t
please lose sleep over this stuff so
that it makes me feel important but the
reality is
training is really good for muscle
growth you just need enough protein
there to support it so we can have the
conversations about optimization they're
important they're valuable but if you're
just saying listen i just want to get
a decent chunk of the return on my
investment here 1.2 uh within most body
composition ranges should be pretty
sufficient um not not to optimize but to
to get a good chunk your gains i mean i
i can tell you exactly what i did in
macro factor and how i approach my own
protein intake so when i started i was
about 120 kilos give or take
um
and so i just locked in 1.2 grams per
kilo as my protein target and i treat
that as a minimum for the day like if if
i'm
and i guess it's higher than 1.2 now
since i've lost some weight but i locked
it in at 1.2
of my initial body weight yeah um 1.2
grams per kilo and so that's like 150
grams per day
and if i fall below that i'm like eh
i should eat more protein today that's
on me uh but that happens pretty rarely
and if i
get at least 150 feel pretty good uh if
i'm 20 30 grams above that feel a little
bit better uh and i have absolutely no
interest in eating more protein than
that right and one thing you'll see by
the way
uh that's rarely discussed um i say that
as if i consume any content whatsoever i
don't know what's being discussed
that was a bluff
that was a bluff
but one of the things i don't hear about
because nobody's shouting it into my
window one of the things you assume is
being discussed is not being discussed
it's not being discussed is that a lot
of people
when you give them a really ambitious
protein intake and their goal is fat
loss sometimes they'll they'll get so
fixated on like oh i can't be under
protein it will actually cause them to
overeat other macros and push their
calorie intake higher for the day
because they'll say like man it's toward
the end of the day i'm 40 grams short on
my protein i can't under eat my protein
and they'll kind of accept the fact like
yeah well this meal is going to bring
some other fat some other carbohydrate
into the mix i'm going to go over my
calorie total for the day by a pretty a
pretty big margin just for the sake of
hitting a minimum protein intake that
frankly
for one day going under that protein
intake is not going to impact them
whatsoever well yeah no so that that's
exactly why i chose the strategy that i
did when i was setting up this diet
uh because for me like you know some
people live on a diet of like chicken
breast and tilapia and like god bless
them if you can do that
more power to you i can't um
i don't know i derive a lot of pleasure
from food and i don't want to eat stuff
that tastes like nothing or is just
super bland and super lean
and so you know
virtually all of my protein sources have
some amount of fat tagging along with
them and you know i'm not eating like
rib eyes every day but i eat a lot of
chicken thighs for example instead of
chicken breasts um or like sirloin
something like a 90 10 steak instead of
like 96 for ground beef or something
like that
and so i think one of the problems i'd
run into previously when i tried to cut
is i would wind up with super low carb
intakes or just wind up way exceeding my
calorie targets just because
there was enough fat coming from my
protein sources that
uh if i were aiming for like 1.8 to 2
grams per kilo or sometimes even up to
2.4 if i was aiming for a pretty high
protein intake
that would necessarily mean severely
restricting carb intake to an amount
that i didn't find sustainable or
really struggling to stay beneath my
calorie targets
and so for me one of the things that has
been helping me on this cut
is
coming to accept a lower protein intake
a little bit more uh and my thought
process was exactly the same as what you
just walked through
i looked at the literature and i said i
feel pretty decent about 1.2 if i lock
that in
and i hit at least 1.2 every day
generally go over by a little bit but if
i hit that every day
i think that that is probably adequate
protein intake for myself
and when i'm aiming for 1.2 instead of
1.8 or 2 or 2.4 or something like that
that just opens up the rest of my diet
so much
that i can still eat enough carbs to not
feel super deprived yeah um
so yeah just
beyond like physiological uh mechanisms
or anything like that just from a pure
practicality perspective that's that's
been huge for me to be able to stick to
a to a consistent calorie deficit yeah
and i've obviously noticed the same
thing with clients as well
um one other protein question that came
my way it came from social media i
forget exactly who asked it
um but i'm basically using it purely to
prove a point
i'm being too honest today aren't i
i'm using it to reinforce a point but i
will answer the question uh
so
the question was there was a new study
that came out showing that higher
protein intake uh in the form of
essential amino acid supplementation i
believe
did not lead to higher
rates of muscle protein synthesis during
energy restriction
so does this mean that our protein needs
are unchanged by caloric restriction
regardless of the magnitude of the
energy deficit and you know this was
something that surprised readers because
uh you know the general kind of typical
advice is if you're going to be in a big
deficit you might want to bump up
protein a little bit you know if you're
especially if you're very lean in a big
deficit protein needs will probably bump
up a little bit
um
what was really interesting is you look
at the study and muscle protein
synthesis rates uh were not different
but
whole body protein balance was we there
was a collection of different
measurements they took to to approximate
you know what's our balance here of
anabolic catabolic processes related to
body protein and the last sentence of
the paper itself is
taken together these results suggest
that higher essential amino acid doses
are necessary to optimize both muscle
and whole body protein status during the
catabolic stress of underfeeding
and
you listen to that statement and you
contrast it with the finding that
energy restriction did not appear to to
or you know high versus low protein in
the in the case of this energy
restriction
it didn't seem to matter for muscle
protein synthesis rates and yet the
take-home point was you're going to want
to bump up your protein if you're
restricting energy and i think
that
that contrast
throws a lot of people for a loop and i
think it highlights a really critical
distinction between
looking at muscle protein synthesis
and assuming that it absolutely
necessarily represents long-term
hypertrophy i think a lot of people have
gotten it in their mind if something
increases muscle protein synthesis if a
increases mps more than b does then a is
better for hypertrophy period i have the
proof it's data right
but
there are many instances in the
literature where that doesn't work out
it breaks down and if you were to
interpret
some of these muscle protein synthesis
papers at face value you would make uh
some conclusions that are erroneous they
they don't it's not just that they
didn't pan out it's that they don't have
face validity
on their surface they don't seem right
because they aren't right so like you
could look at acute muscle protein
synthesis data
and there's literally a paper that would
indicate if taken at face value
that for an obese individual
doing a unilateral study design
their leg that doesn't lift should grow
more muscle than their leg that does
no one would accept that at face value
but if you look at the way the muscle
protein synthesis data is presented that
is the conclusion you'd have to draw if
you're taking it at face value and
you're assuming muscle protein synthesis
equals hypertrophy yeah that was that
was one of the studies that we talked
about during the whole p ratio back and
forth exactly yeah and i said i i will
accept that argument if you if you
believe
that the non-lifting leg should grow
more muscle than the lifting leg i've
never met anyone that would take that at
face value right so you have to check
yourself with some of these
interpretations and make sure that if
you're going to take it at phase out you
have to take all of it at face value you
know
uh
there there are similar um situations
with some of the
research looking at plant versus animal
protein sources where you'll look at
you know acute muscle protein synthesis
data and say there is an enormous
difference between these protein sources
like this animal-based protein source
should should promote so much more
hypertrophy than this plant-based source
but then when we put them in the context
of you know whether we're looking at
individual supplement interventions or
entire diets
that difference that seems huge at the
level of muscle protein synthesis
really shrinks when you start looking at
actual hypertrophy measurements over
time
a different example is with raw versus
cooked eggs i think it's
generally accepted maybe research will
change our perspective on this in the
future but my general understanding is
that raw albumin from egg is far less
digestible than cooked albumin
that's my understanding that i've seen
in in studies i mean that wasn't rocky's
understanding but that was not i mean
there there are differing opinions we
just want to make it clear this isn't
settled science right uh
you know
academic research says one thing
uh balboa at all have some some
differing opinions so do do without what
you will yeah but i mean we're talking
about a difference on the order of like
90 versus 50
digestibility big
uh and then a paper comes out showing
absolutely no difference in muscle
protein synthesis right and so
we have to be very cautious when we
interpret muscle protein synthesis
findings that's not to say that they're
not useful it's not to say they're not
informative it's not to say that the
people using them are doing a poor job
but muscle protein synthesis is by
definition not
hypertrophy
and whenever we look at something a
proxy measure protein quality protein
digestibility muscle protein synthesis
amino acid composition we can use that
information but we have to contextualize
it and use it very carefully and we have
to continuously cross reference that
with applied studies when they're
available actual longitudinal designs
and there's actually a fantastic review
paper that just came out
and the review paper the title is making
sense of muscle protein synthesis a
focus on muscle growth during resistance
training so
this was one of those things i was
starting to feel like a conspiracy
theorist how i would i got to the point
where people would ask me about like hey
what's up with this muscle protein
synthesis thing and i'd be like
yeah i just don't think that has
anything to do with hypertrophy you know
um well so i i remember um
a question that i used to field somewhat
frequently after um
god i forget who the lead author on it
was but there there was a pretty
influential narrative review that came
out that that was just about like
uh nutritional things to optimize muscle
protein synthesis in lifters and one of
the things that it said was for healthy
young people
muscle protein synthesis seems to be
maximized with a protein bolus of 0.25
grams per kilogram which if you weigh 80
kilograms would be like 20 grams of
protein or something like that and then
i think the paper also recommended
four or five uh
protein boluses per day right to
to uh get you the protein you need and
not uh
compact it too much so you might run
into like the muscle full effect and
stuff like that refractory periods
things like that yeah so
you put those two pieces of information
together and we were just arguing that
you know maybe you can get away with
down to about 1.2 grams per kilo of
protein but
the the bulk of the research does still
suggest that if you want to be better
safe than sorry one point optimize
rather than do good enough exactly right
something like 1.6 2.2 something
somewhere in that range
tends to get you where you want to go
um but yeah if you look at
the the data there the acute muscle
protein synthesis stuff and the number
of protein boluses per day you would say
like oh somewhere between 1 and 1.25
grams of protein per kilo of body mass
that should maximize hypertrophy which
does
conflict to some degree with the
longitudinal evidence and so people
people would ask me about that and
they'd be like well what what should
what should i put more stock in this
muscle protein synthesis stuff or the
longitudinal study outcomes and i said i
don't know man like call me a rube but
if i want to know about building muscle
i'm going to look at the studies that
actually
assess building muscle over time so
um yeah this is
i think a cyclical conversation comes up
from time to time and
uh my opinion is when you have
longitudinal studies
you uh pay more attention to the
longitudinal studies right and and like
i said i was getting to the point where
i kept people would say well
you know this acute mps stuff doesn't
match up with the longitudinal stuff and
i'd say
then just go with the longitudinal stuff
you know and and the the just the title
of this new review paper kind of
uh validates that that fact that a lot
of people have been taking this
acute mechanistic muscle protein
synthesis
information and just over extrapolating
it into conditions that aren't
appropriate and making conclusions that
uh might not be appropriate based on the
study design based on you know one of
the big things that comes up with these
studies just to put some degree of
specificity into the conversation it's
like
if you're doing
a single bout of unaccustomed exercise
exercise and you're looking at immediate
muscle protein synthesis response
that's going to correlate very poorly
with long-term hypertrophy potential
there's just too much muscle damage
going on it's you're not getting a good
snapshot so there are instances where
this muscle protein synthesis data
can correlate much better with long-term
longitudinal outcomes it's usually uh
people that are not doing unaccustomed
exercise people that are not totally
untrained and you know engaging in
training for the first time uh
measurements taken over longer time
courses rather than just a few hours
looking at a snapshot there so
once again i don't want to discredit the
research that's been done on most muscle
protein synthesis it's
valuable research it's informative but
when we have
instances where it totally contradicts
more applied longitudinal research
i'm more inclined to go with the
longitudinal stuff
not to say it's perfect you know a lot
of the measurement techniques that we
use for muscle building over you know
eight twelve weeks you could argue that
those aren't perfectly sensitive so
maybe we have to have some caveats there
as well but
getting back to the initial question
you know when someone says hey should i
bump up my protein if i'm lifting and
i'm you know really lean and really
restricting
i'd say man
our good friend uh the good dr helms did
a pretty good systematic review
indicating that in those situations
protein probably ought to be bumped up a
little bit and that was based on some
pretty good applied longitudinal designs
that i feel really good about so if i'm
looking at you know if i on one hand
i've got the body of literature from a
really well done systematic review on
those applied trials and on the other
i've got acute muscle protein synthesis
data
give me the first one every time you
know give me the former rather than the
latter so
if you want to look into that review
paper i am going to link it in the show
notes i think it's i think it's really
well done you know it points out the
issues with
longitudinal body comp assessments which
are fair it points out the
methodological considerations that could
lead to
misapplication of muscle protein
synthesis data
overall very well done and very relevant
to that question that i received
i'm going to do one more here
very very brief uh somebody messaged me
on social media
and asked me like hey what's up with
alkaline water you know does it include
increase blood ph if so does it even
matter
and you know one of the things that
comes up a lot there's a lot of
confusion with these uh alkaline diets
alkaline water
you know one of the questions people ask
is
just simply is it possible to change
blood ph with these types of
interventions
and
i think a lot of people in the
evidence-based community
take a little bit of a shortcut to the
answer no
i don't think that's necessarily true
so we can change blood ph it's just to a
very small extent uh you know with these
types of nutritional interventions and
you know one of the first places i went
with this is like let's just go straight
to the sodium bicarbonate literature
right like it's
a very basic solution that people ingest
and we look at blood ph after ingestion
after exercise and we do see uh in many
in many cases a statistically
significant increase in blood ph
but
human blood is
always going to be slightly alkaline
unless you're
in in a you know potentially precarious
situation where it's become you know
blood ph is getting dysregulated um so
you know some type of acidosis is
happening that's clinic clinically
relevant but generally speaking we're
going to try to keep our blood ph
between
7.35 and 7.45 and so yeah when when we
you know consume an extremely basic
beverage
um in high amounts you know so a big
dose of sodium bicarbonate for example
whether it's capsules or beverage or
whatever
we might see a statistically significant
increase in ph um i still don't know if
alkaline water is going to get you there
though
because i mean if yeah if you're talking
about
20
depending on your size like 15 to 30
grams of sodium bicarbonate taken before
exercise
dude that's
that's a lot more bicarbonate than you
would be consuming in like a liter of
alkaline water yeah there was the reason
i
expanded out into that literature was
because i did see like one or two
studies where
there is a statistically significant
increase
as it was reported because the samples
were enormous
but it just did not matter it was like
the small it was not the same the same
magnitude as sodium bicarbonate but it
was like yeah we found this effect i
assumed there was an enormous
correlation from pre to post-test that
that kind of helped the p-value along
the magnitude was
just so small it couldn't possibly
matter but
i expanded out because i was like okay
are there other
is there a precedent by which consuming
an alkaline you know
a basic alkaline beverage
like you know a sodium bicarbonate
intervention is there a precedent for
this where we could see an increase and
so the answer is yes
but the answer is also that i just when
it comes to alkaline water like
it's a bit of a shortcut to say like no
it absolutely never could possibly have
any measurable impact on ph but
it just doesn't matter like the the idea
that alkaline water you're going to
consume it and it's going to have a
positive effect on i mean they make all
sorts of claims about stuff ranging from
bone health all the way to like cancer
prevention are you going to consume
alkaline water that's going to change
your blood ph
probably not
even if there was an effect it'd be so
small as to be completely negligible and
will it impact any relevant health
related outcome
none that i can think of so
functionally it doesn't matter the
answer to this question like is there
any reason to be drinking alkaline water
in my opinion no
but i did want to at least acknowledge
like there there are ways that blood ph
can change to a measurable measurable
degree
but the body has so many
redundant mechanisms to keep it within a
fairly tight operating range
the ph thing just doesn't seem to matter
like you can try to drive it over 7.45
but i mean alkaline water like you said
ain't gonna do it i mean that also still
wouldn't be a good thing no it'd
when people talk about uh like health
risk from blood ph dysregulation they're
generally thinking about
pretty extreme acidosis yeah i mean if
you could put yourself in a comparable
state of alkalosis that would be just as
bad it would not yeah that's yeah it
would not be good it's kind of like one
of those things um i think kind of a
slightly analogous situation is when
people talk about
uh
doing all sorts of weird stuff with
sodium potassium balance
and it's like
it's so important to physiological
function that there are a lot of
redundant mechanisms to keep it within a
tight operating range to the extent
possible
and
in the off chance you are able to
override that stuff it's bad
you know
yeah not good yeah so um when it comes
to alkaline water uh
the the reason i brought up the study
was just because someone
was um they were confused you know they
said like hey man uh everyone's saying
that this can't increase blood ph but
here's a study on pubmed which is
supposed to mean something and it did
and i looked at it i said yes it did it
was statistically significant
it was physiologically meaningless and
that's a good thing you know if if all
of a sudden blood ph was nine you're
screwed yeah you're so screwed it
wouldn't happen but but yeah so alkaline
water not worth your time not worth your
money um but if you ever see um
i think it's good to know that when
you're
looking at other research like so for
example sodium bicarb you shouldn't look
at a study that says oh by the way blood
ph increased p is .04 shouldn't look at
that and say well this study got botched
because that that's not technically
accurate yeah yeah uh so you you tried
to re you tried to address that question
uh respectfully sure i just want to dunk
a little bit uh i would say
god probably a dozen different times
like this isn't just a one or two time
occurrence i'll stumble across on my
like instagram discover page um
like health tips instagram accounts
and i love that [ __ ] like i
if people probably have a completely
inaccurate assumption of what my what my
media consumption habits are i spend
virtually all of my time
seeking out good information
either on pubmed or journal websites or
talking to people who i respect
i
i
consume virtually no
kind of like solid quote unquote fitness
industry content like i know there are
people out there doing good work
i just i just don't read it um
when i am consuming
non-serious content
i'm looking for the trash i want to see
the garbage
i love it i think a lot of people see
that stuff and they get frustrated
they're like oh no the state of the
industry this is so bad
i'm very nihilistic
i fundamentally don't think anything is
going to get that much better so i just
bathe in it i i enjoy it i find it so
funny um
so anyway in
wading into just the pure
depths of instagram [ __ ]
i've come across
like i said probably at least a dozen
posts from health and fitness
influencers saying look you need to
alkalize your body that's good for you
it's going to prevent cancer it's going
to give you so much mental clarity and
energy
and here are some tips to do it first
consume alco alkaline water duh of
course everyone knows that that's the
good stuff but here's another tip did
you know
uh citrus also alkalizes your body so
put a put a squeeze of lemon juice in
your alkaline water
and i'm sure
95 of people listening to this
understand why that's funny
ph isn't
it's not a magical thing uh ph stands
for potential hydrogen um so if it's in
so it's basically a measure of how much
hydrogen which like free hydrogen that
is acid uh how much free hydrogen a
thing can accept uh and so
like that that's a pure kind of like
applied chemistry base based measurement
if you put an acid in a basic substance
it necessarily raises the ph or
necessarily lowers the ph and makes it
more acidic so
i mean if if alkaline water could
elevate blood ph make it more basic
it does i don't give a [ __ ] if you're
claiming that there are magical
properties of lemons that can also
increase blood ph if you put acidic
lemon juice in alkaline water that
shit's not alkaline water anymore or at
least you're making it less alkaline
than it previously was absolutely
incredible i love it so much uh if you
find
bad fitness content send it to me uh and
not just
if it's just like a one-off or someone's
just kind of like ah they post some
workout tips and ah whatever and they
just have a stinker i don't care about
that that's not the good stuff you want
the shock value i want i want the worst
of the worst and here's the gold mine if
you find a
a single account that like
40 to 70 of what they post
is pure garbage
send it to me i love it i want to fill
my instagram feed with meme pages dog
pages and the worst fitness content
imaginable so uh
anyway
that's all i'm gonna say if if you come
across someone who's pushing alkaline
water in combination with citrus fruit
cut up cut them out of your life and put
them into mine you should expand you you
mentioned dog pages
really any mammal will do i've got a lot
of raccoon pages i've got some bear
pages i'm a sucker for animal friend
accounts
what does that mean like two animals of
a different species that are buddies
yeah yeah yeah like cross species
friendships yeah i like that a lot um
but yeah yesterday i was pretty deep
looking at a bunch of panda content the
red panda
very cute very good stuff um but i guess
the moral of the story is
there's no reason to drink alkaline
water but um technically
you know certain interventions could
have a statistically significant
significant effect on blood ph
um but it's still going to stay within
that tight range that that's typical
because
i mean
we're good at managing that and we're
pretty lucky that we're good at managing
that
there's one other thing i was going to
say about this
and i have completely lost it um
if it comes back to me
i will let you know do i see you
i see in the outline you have some stuff
about breathing and how that regulates
ph no i was going to get into the
mechanisms of how we regulate ph but
we're just good at it um
and good for us
if you want to alkyl if you want to
alkalize your body
uh one thing you could do is just
hyperventilate for a while
yeah like if you there was a uh um did
you cover that in mass i did yeah yeah
um but yeah if you wanted
to just see like hey if i were to
alkalize my body how would that make me
feel you can get kind you can get
relatively close to the limits of
human blood alkalinity just via
respiratory alkalosis
which you can get to just by
hyperventilating you're blowing off co2
uh and like the co2 carbonic acid
relationship like that that's one of the
ways that your body regulates ph via
your lungs and kidneys like those are
the two main things so if you're just
blowing off a ton of co2 by
hyperventilating you put yourself in in
a state of respiratory alkalosis
so you know if you want to see
how you feel uh as your as your blood ph
approaches uh 7.45
you can do it um
have fun
yes um i remember the thing i was gonna
say thank you for uh filling that time
there with a lovely anecdote with good
advice with good advice
um
one thing to keep in mind if you are
looking through this literature is that
urine ph is way more responsive to
dietary fluctuations than blood ph so
be sure not to confuse those sometimes
we kind of convince ourselves oh
blood values urine values whatever it's
all the same but one of the redundant
mechanisms you know we have all these
overlapping mechanisms for ph control
one of the mechanisms is that your
kidneys can kind of decide hey
how much should we be pumping into the
urine here to just kind of balance
things out yeah that is why blood ph can
be so tightly controlled yeah like
you're uh
what is it your entire blood volume
filters through your kidneys every five
minutes or something like that i've
never heard that but i believe it and
it's also crazy at the same time i
believe that's the case so yeah if you
uh manage to create a relatively large
perturbation in blood ph
uh
via some
non-pathological means uh
you're you're going to like all of that
blood that you just alkalized is going
to pass through your kidneys within the
next five minutes and if the level of
alkalinity got
high enough to even begin threatening uh
your body's homeostasis
you're just gonna put a bunch of
bicarbonate in your urine and now now
your blood ph is back to normal so
that is another thing like even if you
can perturb blood ph those perturbations
are going to be very short-lived oh yeah
very transient very short-lived and and
that is why urine ph can vary quite a
bit more like if if something kind of
acidic is going on and you have
more acidity in your blood uh those
excess hydrogen ions are going to very
quickly be filtered into urine and
you're going to piss them out if your
body does get considerably more alkaline
um and and you'll you'll also uh
increase respiration to alkalize your
blood as well i don't want to make it
sound like it's all urine uh but yeah if
your body gets more alkaline you'll just
put more bicarbonate in your urine and
and get rid of it so yeah any
perturbations not only are they
generally quite small but they're also
quite short-lived as well
yep all right
to play us out here let's stay on theme
we've talked a lot about protein today
uh you made some protein bread i've not
tried it but i am excited to hear about
it you should try some after this i will
all right so um
yeah i have gone on record on the
podcast saying that protein versions of
normal foods are generally trash and if
people if someone makes one and they say
that it is as good as the real thing
they are deluding themselves
and i stand by that but
but but
uh i i have recently started
experimenting
with trying to make protein bread um
biggest reason for that is like
uh sometimes like i i generally have a
variable amount of calories left at the
end of the day uh after dinner i'll have
generally somewhere between
one and maybe 500 calories left over and
and i'm not a stickler for hitting my
calorie number dead on the head but you
know if if i'm under by enough
i'll be like yeah you know i i should
eat a little something to get a little
bit closer um
and so when i'm under on fat or carbs
i
have things in my life that i can go to
like yeah a spoonful of peanut butter
some craisins really it's peanut butter
and craisins those are those are my
go-to's but if i if i do get close to
the end of the day and i'm like 20 grams
under on protein
um
and
you know maybe i have 300 calories left
i don't want to just like get a very
small bowl of my meal prep food that
seems sad
i don't keep protein bars on hand and i
personally just despise protein shakes
if someone else likes them no judgment
so currently what my approach has been
is just to make a couple eggs
but i don't always feel like cooking
something at 11 pm so i was like okay
i want something that i i can get some
protein in
um that hopefully will keep uh
at room temperature for a reasonably
long period of time uh
and that won't be
too much of an abomination
so i decided hey
what if i just replace some of the flour
and bread with casein
and the reason i thought that is casein
behaves pretty nicely for baking
applications here's another heuristic if
someone is saying hey i'm making a
protein version of this food and you
look at the ingredients list and you see
whey protein heavily featured they're
lying to you whey protein does not bake
well it gets a crumbly texture uh
whey protein is already slightly bitter
and applying heat i think tends to
enhance the bitterness
um
you can put enough other [ __ ] in
whatever you're making to mask way a
little bit but it really doesn't behave
nicely for most baking applications the
texture is a giveaway yeah it's bad it's
not good casein behaves very well so
casein hydrates much like
wheat flour does like it it behaves very
similarly
um
like it it won't form gluten obviously
because it doesn't have gluten in it but
a lot of the ways it behaves is very
reminiscent of flour when it's hydrated
um
and it also has a has a pretty mild
taste like
it tastes
if you just put a bunch of casein in
water and chugged it it's not going to
be the best tasting thing in the world
but it does have a very mild taste and i
don't think the taste gets worse when
you apply heat
so i
i was just kind of playing around with
like how much casein would i need to put
in some dinner rolls to give them enough
protein that i could eat one or two
dinner rolls and get a non-negligible
amount of protein from it
and so it turned out that with
a like 900 gram of flour dinner roll
recipe if i've replaced 250 grams with
casein
i was i was pretty enthused with what
the macros looked like so i said yeah
[ __ ] it i'm gonna try it and so last
weekend i made a batch of protein bread
and again i'm not gonna say that it was
as good as the real thing but it was
like
90 as good as the real thing and
honestly
my complaints with it don't relate to
the casing um i did not
trust my baking skills enough and so
since i was i was thinking like since
i'm reducing the gluten content i want
to put another binder in there just to
make sure
that everything holds together the way i
want it to and so i added three whole
eggs and so really my only complaint
about the bread is it has
a slightly stronger eggy flavor than i
prefer
uh and it's it's not particularly bad
it's not offensive and since these are
dinner rolls like if you microwave it
and slap a little butter on it it
completely uh covers the eggy flavor so
i would say that i'm
90
of the way to
having a protein bread recipe that i'm
very very satisfied with so uh
this episode's gonna come out on
thursday
probably on friday
if you're listening to this pretty soon
after it comes out i am going to go
attempt number two for protein bread and
this time i'm leaning into something
kind of brioche so i'm gonna replace the
three eggs
with egg yolks uh probably six yolks
and
um
probably increase
the amount of honey that i put in the
bread make it a little bit sweeter so if
if there is still any
uh eggy taste or if some of the casein
flavor starts coming through a little
more a little bit of honey will cover
for that and maybe a touch of butter as
well
i'll play around with the recipe just
in theory to see what would still give
me macros i liked um
but i'm gonna be making that uh between
friday and saturday because i'm gonna go
with an overnight proof
so uh keep an eye on my instagram
stories if i
if i perfect protein bread i think this
will be a game changer if you're into
fitness and you're also into home baking
uh i would i would strongly recommend
you try it out uh you can you can follow
along this weekend
and uh i mean so the macros i don't want
to
sound like i'm teasing anything for this
first batch of protein bread i made i
think it was
177 calories per roll
uh with 14 grams of protein 23 grams of
carbs and three grams of fat per roll
that's pretty good it's not bad yeah so
yeah if i can get away
with i think bumping the carbs up to
maybe 26 27 per roll and the fat up to
even as high as like six or seven grams
per roll that would still match the
macro splits that i'm generally aiming
for i might just be able to subsist on
an all-bread diet which honestly that
that would slap what more could you want
but uh yeah that that's coming this
weekend keep an eye on my instagram
stories
and uh
beyond that just as a general point of
advice if you want to try to make like
protein brownies protein cookies protein
muffins whatever really use anything
except for whey protein the reason whey
protein is so popular for protein shakes
is because it does everything you
wouldn't want protein to do for baking
purposes
it doesn't hydrate well
it dissolves really well so it's it's
thin in solution
and generally if you're trying to make
moist tender baked goods you want the
opposite like you don't want something
to disappear in solution you want
something to be
like sucking in water and hydrating the
same way that flour does
and casein does that for you
and other popular proteins like i've
heard some people having success with
pea protein i've heard some people
having success with soy protein
um
i i don't think either of those are
quite as good as casein but they can get
the job done but really just
don't try to make protein desserts with
whey
try literally any other protein and
you'll uh you'll probably wind up with
better results
all right good stuff so follow along
greg's personal instagram personal one
right yeah and uh you can watch the
experiment this very weekend
as always thanks so much for joining us
for this episode
of the stronger by science podcast and
we will be back soon with another